nearly three years ago donald trump came
to office
and he promised peace and prosperity for
america
and this he has delivered now even with
the heavy anvil of the mueller
investigation tied around his neck
the president has worked tirelessly to
drain the swamp with
massive deregulation phenomenal judges
and a tax cut for working families
markets are up wages are up unemployment
is way down across
all key demographic groups and on
foreign policy
he has likewise been remarkably
consistent
on his pledge to put america first he
said he was going to do this and he's
doing it he's winding down
foreign entanglements long-term military
interventions
that i seem to recall democrats used to
be against
they've been warring for many years it's
unnatural for us but it's sort of
natural for them they fight
and they fight long and they fight hard
and they've been fighting syria for a
long time and on the border that's the
border with syria
and i say why are we protecting syria's
land assad's not a friend of ours why
are we protecting their land
now remember when democrats embrace this
anti-interventionist approach
this war diminishes our security our
standing in the world
our military our economy and the
resources that we need to confront the
challenges
of the 21st century by any measure our
single-minded and open-ended focus on
iraq
is not a sound strategy for keeping
america safe
but now that's all apparently just
totally out the window last night tulsi
gabbard
was the only person on that democrat
debate stage
who on this issue really channeled obama
you would continue this policy of the
u.s actually providing arms and support
to terrorist groups
in syria because they are the ones who
have been the ground force
in this regime change war no you can
embrace
or you can put an end to endless war
without embracing donald trump
and the regime change war is the
question what we are doing is an endless
war if it's not yet another regime
change war
please allow them to respond what we're
doing or what we were doing
in syria was keeping our word
oh nice repeat well by the end of the
evening it was obvious that the
democrats
will say and do at this point almost
anything including
contort their own views on key issues
just to oppose trump now i don't recall
any of them voicing any great concern
for what might happen to the kurds back
in 2012
when obama drew his red line and didn't
enforce it the kurds were still
implicated there remember
well but maybe it was because they
started seeing polls
on invading syria and what were they
like back then well consider what gallup
found
68 percent to 24 of americans oppose
military action
quote to attempt to end the conflict
even if
all economic and diplomatic efforts
failed to end the civil war in syria
so have americans today really become
newly pro-interventionist
i don't think so but the democrats maybe
they have all because
that keeps them in opposition to trump
the aoc plus three party essentially
believes that the american way of life
in many ways has become evil and
unsustainable
the candidates think trump's a menace
and he's got to go
but other than that their policy
prescriptions are kind of a
mishmash biden thinks that if he wins
things will just magically go back to
obama that whole era when
democrats were partying at the white
house with stevie wonder and tom hanks
as for warren and sanders they want to
adopt a european style socialist
approach which
last time i checked isn't working
anywhere in the world now
klobuchar buddha judge well they're
trying to hold themselves out i guess as
more moderate
more reasonable democrats but neither of
them can get out of single digits in the
polls
and beto he's basically a less
interesting and less intelligent aoc
castro he's a radical open borders
nightmare
booker thinks democrats should just be
nicer to each other
but that's realistic well they're all
either running
to be vice president or they're running
because they don't have anything better
to do i don't know
but cnn did try its best to help them
all
by staying away from certain topics
altogether last night
for instance there were zero questions
or discussion
about the most important threat to
american long-term security
talking about that small innocuous
country called china
mentioned a few times it was all in
passing
so we're supposed to take this crowd
seriously
now remember voters are supposed to
believe elizabeth warren
is the new smart and savvy front-runner
mayor buddhist you say senator warren
has been quote
evasive about how she's going to pay for
medicare for all
well we heard it tonight a yes or no
question that didn't get a yes or no
answer your signature senator is to have
a plan for everything
except this so let's be clear whenever
someone hears the term
medicare for all who want it understand
what that really means
it's medicare for all who can afford it
i don't understand why you believe
the only way to deliver affordable
coverage to everybody is to obliterate
private
plans well wait a second she's going to
out negotiate
president xi when she can't handle the
mayor of south bend
i don't think so now what we've learned
from these debates i think generally is
the following
the agendalist democrats have no china
policy other than complaining about
trump's tariffs
no coherent trade policy except we'll
work with the europeans more
okay like obama didn't already try that
and fail they have
no coherent health care policy and
someone who abolished health insurance
as you saw altogether and wildly
unpopular others want a hybrid of sorts
but it's still a jumble
they have no plan to raise your standard
of living that i can see
they've actually kind of just given up
even trying to argue that point
but their answer for everything is to
tax it
if it moves tax it if it doesn't
tax it i do think it is appropriate to
acknowledge
that taxes will go up for people making
between
50 and 75 000 a year their taxes are
gonna go up about five thousand dollars
we should look at what germany france
denmark and sweden still have which is a
value-added tax
billionaires are making their money off
their accumulated wealth
we need a wealth tax sometimes i think
that
senator warren is is more focused on
being punitive
now you know it's bad when even beta was
saying there whoa this is
a little too much for the taxes now even
with the advanced age of the three top
candidates
at times it felt like last night you
were watching a bunch of 19 year old
dilettante sitting around their dorm
common area
shooting the bull about stuff they just
read the night before so cutting edge
that means that our whole solar system
could be like one tiny atom
in the fingernail of some other giant
being
oh this is too much if it were only that
interesting
now on issue after issue donald trump
has literally turned the democrats into
human pretzels
they're all tied up in knots they're
defining themselves and a lot of other
people out there are doing the same
thing but let's focus on the democrats
they're defining themselves only through
their opposition to trump
now they used to be skeptical of spy
agencies and government surveillance
but they now embrace the deep state's
powers
they used to be for better trade deals
to help blue collar workers
but they won't support the usmca
they used to be for getting out of
endless wars as i said but now they want
back in
there is no consistency whatsoever
except on you know
as many i got abortion or those things i
guess
obama actually was a smart person i
didn't agree with him a lot but
really smart incredibly talented
politician
elizabeth warren what am i missing she
cannot hold a candle to obama
none of the democrats that i can see on
that stage can
the democrats hate trump but have a
whole lot of nothing to replace him
and i think smart people in the party
know it
look at the new moody study out today
their calculations show a 2020 map
that looks like this and when you step
back and you looked at that
field last night on that democrat debate
stage
you can see why so many democrats think
impeachment
even if it takes secret hearings is
their only answer
and that's the angle